YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
I want to begin by giving
some comments regarding
the Wikipedia assignment.
So I sent out an email
about this last night.
And so first of all, thank
you for your contributions
to this assignment,
to Wikipedia.
It plays a really important role
in educating a wider audience
what this subject is about
because as many of you
have experienced,
the first time--
if you heard of
some term, you have
no idea what it is,
you put it into Google,
and often Wikipedia's entry
is one of the top results that
come up.
And what gets written
in there actually
plays a fairly influential role
in educating a broader audience
about what this topic is about.
And so I want to emphasize
that this is not simply
some homework assignment.
It's something that is
a real contribution.
And it's something
that contributes
to the dissemination
of knowledge.
And for that, it is really
important to do a good job,
to do it right, to do it well,
so that next time someone--
maybe even yourselves--
maybe you've
forgotten what the subject
is about and go back
and you want to look it up
again and remind yourself.
You will have a useful
resource to look into.
But also let's say someone
wants to find out what
is external graph theory about?
What is additive
combinatorics about?
You want them to land on
the page that points you
to the right type of
places, that points you
to useful resources, that opens
doors so that you can explore
further.
And some of the
contributions, indeed,
serve you well in that purpose.
It opens doors to many things.
And part of the spirit
of this assignment
is for you to do
your own research,
do your own literature search,
to learn more about a subject,
more than what has been
taught in these lectures
so that you can write
about it on Wikipedia.
You can link to
more references, you
know, show the world what
the subject is about.
OK, continuing with
our program, so we
spent the past few lectures
developing tools regarding
the structure of set
addition so that we
can prove Freiman's theorem.
So that's been our goal
for the past few lectures.
And today we'll finally
prove Freiman's theorem.
But let me first remind
you the statement--
so in Freiman's theorem, we
would like to show that if you
are in a subset--
if you're in the integers, you
have a set A that has bounded
doubling-- doubling
constant, constant k--
then the said must be contained
in a small, generalized
arithmetic progression,
down to dimension and size,
only a constant
factor larger than a.
We developed various tools the
past three lectures building up
to your intermediate results.
But we also collected this
very nice set of tools
for proving Freiman's theorem.
So let me review
some of them, which
we'll encounter again today.
PlünneckeRuzsa inequality tells
you that if you have a set with
small doubling, then the
further iterated sums are also
controlled.
So I want you to think of these
parameters as k is a constant,
so k to the some power
is still a constant,
but also I don't really care
about polynomial changes in k.
So I-- you know, we should
ignore polynomial changes in k
and view this constant more or
less as the original k itself.
So if some is-- the a plus a
is around the same size as a,
then further iterations also do
not change the sizes very much.
Ruzsa covering lemma: so
this was some statement
that if x plus b looks like
it could be covered by copies
of b, just in terms of their
sizes alone, then in fact,
x could be covered by a
small number of translates
of a slightly larger ball.
But here B can be any set.
We had a thing called
Ruzsa modeling lemma.
In particular, a
consequence of it
is that if a has small
doubling, then there
exists the prime n
that's not too much
bigger than the size of a,
and a very large proportion--
an eighth of a subset
of an eighth of a such
that this subset
a prime is prime
and 8 isomorphic to
a subset of z mod n.
So even though you
start with a set that's
potentially very
spread out, provided
they have small
doubling, I can pick out
a pretty large piece
of it and model it
by something in a fairly
small cyclic group.
And here the modeling
is 8 isomorphic,
so it preserves sums
up to eight term sums.
We had Bogolyubovs
lemma so now we're
inside a small cyclic
group of a large subset
of a small cyclic group.
Then Bogolyubovs lemma says
that 2a minus 2a contains
a large bore set, of large
structure within the situated
subset.
And last time we showed that
the geometry of numbers,
Minkowskis second
term, one can deduce
that every bore set of small
dimension and small width
contains--
of large width contains a
proper GAP that's pretty large.
So putting these two together,
putting the last two things
together, we obtain
that if you have
a subset of the cyclic
group and n is prime--
OK, so here in previous
statement n is prime.
So n is prime.
And a is pretty large.
Then 2a minus 2a contains a
proper generalized arithmetic
progression of dimension at
most alpha to the minus 2
and size at least 1 over
40 to the d times n.
So it's just starting
from the size of a.
2a minus 2a contains
a pretty large GAP.
So we're going to put
all of these ingredients
together and show
that you can now
contain the original
set, a, in a small GAP.
So just from knowing that some
subset of it, 2a minus 2a,
so think 2a prime minus 2a
prime, contains this large GAP.
We're going to use it to
boost it up to a cover.
So now let's prove
Freiman's theorem.
Using the modeling lemma--
using the modeling lemma--
the corollary of the modeling
lemma-- we find that
since a plus a is size
at most k kind of
size of a, there
exists some prime n at
most 2k to the 16 times a.
And so I'm just copying the
consequence of this modeling
lemma.
So I find a pretty large subset
of a such that a prime is prime
and 8 isomorphic to
a subset of z mod n.
Now, applying the
final corollary
with alpha being the size
of this a prime, which
is at least the size of a over
n, which is at least 1 over 16
to the times k to the
power 16, so all constants.
We see that 2a prime minus--
so let me actually-- let
me change the letters
and call a prime b so I don't
have to keep on writing primes.
So subset of a is called b.
OK, so 2b minus 2b now
contains a large GAP.
And the GAP has
dimension d bounded.
So the dimension is bounded
by alpha to the minus 2.
So it's some constant.
And the size is pretty large.
So size is at least 1 over 40 d.
If you only care
about constants,
just remember that everything
that depends on k or d
is a constant.
OK.
Because b is Freiman's
8 isomorphic,
b is Freiman 8 isomorphic to--
ah, sorry.
b is-- a prime is a subset of a
and b is the subset of z mod--
b is a subset of z mod n that
a prime is 8 isomorphic, too.
So since b is 8 isomorphic
to a prime, every GAP in b--
so if you think about what
8 isomorphism preserves,
you find that if you look at 2b
minus 2b, it must be 2 prime--
2 isomorphic to 2a
prime minus 2a prime.
So the point of
prime and isomorphism
is that we just want to preserve
enough additive structure.
Well, we're doing to preserve
all the additive structure,
but just enough
additive structure
to do what we need to do.
And being able to preserve
an arithmetic progression,
or in general or generalized
arithmetic progression,
requires you to preserve
Freiman 2 isomorphism.
And that's where the a comes in.
So I want to analyze
2b minus 2b and I
want that to preserve
2 isomorphisms.
So initially I want b to
preserve 8 isomorphisms.
So 2b minus 2b is Freiman
isomorphic to 2a prime minus 2a
prime.
So the GAP, which we found
earlier in 2B minus 2B
is mapped via this
Freiman isomorphism
to a proper GAP,
which we'll call q,
now setting aside 2a
minus 2a and preserving
the same dimension and size.
So Freiman isomorphisms
are good for preserving
these partial additive
structures like GAPs.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are we using
this smaller structure to be
[INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: Correct.
So question is, we're using--
so because we have to
pass the 2b minus 2b,
we want 2b minus 2b to be
prime and isomorphic to 2a
prime minus 2a prime.
So that's why in
the proof I want b
to be 8 isomorphic to a prime.
So you see, so I'm skipping
details of this step.
But if you read the definition
of Freiman's s isomorphism,
you see that this
implication holds.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: No.
2 isomorphism is a
weaker condition.
2 isomorphism just means that
you are preserving two y sums.
So think about the definition
of Freiman 2 isomorphisms.
In particular, if two sets
are Freiman 2 isomorphic
and you have a arithmetic
progression in one,
then that arithmetic progression
is also an arithmetic
progression in the other.
So it's just enough
additive structure
to preserve things like
arithmetic progressions
and generalized
arithmetic progressions.
OK.
So we found this large
GAP in 2a minus 2a.
So this is very good.
So we wanted to
contain a in the GAP.
Seems that by now we're
doing something slightly
in the opposite direction.
We find a large GAP
within 2a minus 2a.
But something we've
seen before, we're
going to use this to boost
ourselves to a covering of a
via the Ruzsa covering lemma.
So once you find
this large structure,
you can now try to take
translates of it to cover a.
And this is-- if there's
any takeaway from the spirit
of this proof is this idea.
Even though I want to cover
the whole set, it's OK.
I just find a large
structure within it
and then I use
translaters to cover.
How do we do this?
So since q is
containing 2a minus 2a,
we find that q plus a is
containing 3a minus 2a.
Therefore, by Plünnecke-Ruzsa--
by Plünnecke-Ruzsa inequality,
the size of cube plus a is at
most the size of 3a minus 2a,
which is, at most, k to the
fifth power times the size
of a.
And I claim that this
final quantity is also not
so different from the
size of cube, because--
so all of these--
I mean, the point
here is, we are
doing all of these
transformations,
passing down to subsets, putting
something bigger, putting--
getting to something smaller,
but each time we only
loose something that
is polynomial in k.
We're not losing much more.
I am also only losing
a constant factor.
There is sometimes a bit
more than polynomial,
but any case, we're losing only
a constant factor at each step.
So in particular, since n upper
bounds the size of a prime
is here where we ended up
embedding into z modern,
n is larger than a prime, which
is at least a constant fraction
of a and the size
of q is at least 1
over 40 raised d times n.
So we find that this bound--
upper bound earlier on q plus a.
We can write it in
terms of size of cube
where k prime is-- you put
all of these numbers together.
What it is specifically
doesn't matter so much,
other than that
it is a constant.
d is polynomial in k.
So what we have here is
something that is exponential,
polynomial of k.
OK, so now we're in a position
to apply the Ruzsa covering
lemma.
So look at that
statement up there.
So what is the
saying, that a plus q
looks like it could be covered
by q, just in terms of size.
So I should expect to cover a
by a small number of translates
of q minus q.
So by covering lemma, a is
containing some x plus q
minus q for some x in
a where the size of x
is at most k prime.
I claim-- so we've
covered a by something.
q is a GAP.
x is a bounded size
set, and I claim
that this is the type of object
that we're happy to have.
Just to spell out
some details, first
note that x is contained in a
GAP dimension x or x minus 1
with length 2 in each direction.
So add a new direction
for every element of x.
It's wasteful, but
everything's constant.
And recall that the
dimension of Q as a GAP is d.
So x plus q minus q is
contained in a GAP of dimension.
OK, so what's the dimension?
So when I do q minus q,
it's like taking a box
and doubling its dimension--
doubling its lengths.
I'm not changing the
number of dimensions.
So the dimension of
q minus q is still d.
The dimension of x is,
at most, the size of x.
All of these things
are constants.
So we're happy.
But to spell it out,
the constant here is--
well, k prime is what
we wrote up there.
So this is a constant.
And the size-- so what
is the size of the GAP
that contains this guy here?
So I'm expanding x to a GAP
by adding a new direction
for every element of x.
And I might expand
that size a little bit.
But the size of this GAP that
contains x is no more than 2
to the power x--
2 raised to the size of x.
What is the size
of GAP q minus q?
So q is the GAP of dimension d.
And we know that a
GAP of dimension d
has doubling constant
and those 2 to the d--
2 to the d times the size of q.
OK.
And because q is
contained in qa minus 2a,
we find that q is
contained in 2a minus 2a.
And 2 to the x, well, I
know what the site of x
is bounded by, it's k prime
plus the size of x is--
size of x is, at most, k prime.
And then I have 2
to the d over here,
so 2a minus 2a by
Plünnecke-Ruzsa is at most k
to the 4 times the size of a.
OK, you put everything together,
we find that this bound here
is doubly exponential in
the-- it's a polynomial in k.
And that's it.
This proves Freiman's theory.
Now, to recap-- we went
through several steps.
So first, using
the modeling lemma,
we know that if a set
a has small doubling,
then we can pass a large
part of a to a relatively
small cyclic group.
Going to work inside
our cyclic group.
Using Bogolyubovs lemma and its
geometry of numbers corollary,
we find that inside
the cyclic group,
the corresponding set,
which we called b,
is such that 2b minus
2b contains a large GAP.
We pass that GAP back
to the original set
a because we are preserving
8 isomorphisms Freiman 8
isomorphisms in
Ruzsa modeling lemma
so we can pass to
the original set a
and find the large
GAP in 2a minus 2a.
Once we find this
large GAP 2a minus 2a,
then we're going to
use the Ruzsa covering
lemma to contain a inside a
small number of translates
of this GAP.
OK.
You put all of these things
together and the appropriate
bounds coming from
Plünnecke-Ruzsa inequalities
and you get a final theorem.
And this is the proof
of Freiman's theorem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
The question is how
do you make it proper?
Up until the step with
q, it is still proper.
So the very last step
over here it is--
you might have
destroyed properness.
So this proof here doesn't
give you properness.
So I mentioned at the beginning
that in Freiman's theorem,
you can obtain properness
of the additional arguments.
So that I'm not going to show.
There's some more work which is
related to geometry of numbers.
So for example, you can look up
in the textbook by Tao and Vu,
and see how to get from a GAP
to contain it in a proper GAP,
without losing too
much in terms of size.
So think about it this way--
when do you have something
which is not proper?
When you have-- and if
some linear dependence,
you have some integer
linear dependence.
And in that case, you
kind of lost a dimension.
When you have improperness, you
actually go down a dimension.
But then you need
to salvage the size,
make sure that the size
doesn't blow up too much.
And so there are some
arguments to be done there.
And we're not going
to do it here.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
guess my [INAUDIBLE]
do they change [INAUDIBLE]
within the proof,
like say [INAUDIBLE]
q or whatever?
Or do they use the same
proof, but later on,
say that [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, good.
Yeah, so the question
is, to get properness,
do I have to modify the proof,
or can I use Freiman's theorem
as witness of a black box.
So my understanding
is that I can
use the statement as a black
box and obtain properness.
But if you want to
get good bounds,
maybe you have to go into
the proof, although that,
I'm not sure.
OK, any more questions?
So this took a while.
This was the most involved
proof we've done in this course
so far, in proving
Freiman's theorem.
We had to develop a
large number of tools.
And we came up--
so we eventually arrived at--
it's a beautiful theorem.
So this is a
fantastic result that
gives you an inverse
structure, something--
we know that GAP's
have small doubling.
And conversely, if something
has a small doubling,
it has to, in some
sense, look like a GAP.
So you see that the
proof is quite involved
and has a lot of
beautiful ideas.
In the remainder
of today's lecture,
I want to present some remarks
on additional extensions
and generalizations
of Freiman's theorem.
And while we're not
going to do any proofs,
there's a lot of deep
and beautiful mathematics
that are involved
in the subject.
So I want to take you on a
tour through some more things
that we can talk about when
it comes to Freiman's theorem.
But first, let me
mention a few things
that I mentioned very
quickly when we first
introduced Freiman's
theorem, namely
some remarks on the bounds.
So the proof that we
just saw gives you
a bound, which is basically
exponential in the dimension
and doubly exponential
for the size blow-up.
They're all constants, so if
you only care about constants,
then this is just fine.
But you may ask, are we
losing too much here?
What is the right
type of dependence?
So what is the right
So we saw an example.
So we saw an example where
if you start with A being
a highly dissociated set,
where there is basically
no additive structure
within A, then you do need--
so this example shows that
you cannot do better than
polynomial--
well, actually, than linear
in K, in the dimension,
and exponential in
the size blow-up.
So in particular, you
do need to blow up
the size by some
exponential quantity in K.
So here, K is roughly the size
of A over 2 in this example.
And you can create
modifications of the example
to keep K constant
and A getting larger.
But the point is that you
cannot do better than this type
of dependence simply
from that example.
And it's conjecture
that that is the truth.
We're almost there in
proving this conjecture,
but not quite, although
the proof that we just gave
is somewhat far, because you
lose an exponent in each bound.
There is a refinement of the
final step in the argument,
so let me comment on that.
So we can refine the final
step or the final steps
in the proof to get
polynomial bounds.
And to get a polynomial
bounds, which
is much more in
the right ballpark
compared to what we got.
And the idea is
basically over here,
we used the Ruzsa
covering lemma.
So we started with
that Q up there.
So up until this point, you
should think of this step
as everything coming from
Bogolyubov and its corollary.
So that stays the same.
And now the question is starting
with our Q, what would you use?
How would you use this
Q to try to cover it?
Well, what we do, we apply
Ruzsa covering lemma.
Remember how the proof of
Ruzsa covering lemma goes.
You take a maximal
set of translates,
disjoint translates.
And if you blow
everything up a factor 2,
then you've got a cover.
But it turns out to
be somewhat wasteful.
And you see, there was a lot
of waste in going from x to 2
to the x.
So you could do that
step more slowly.
So starting with Q,
cover now some, not all
of A. So cover parts of A by
translates of 2 minus Q, say.
So we do Ruzsa
covering lemma, you
don't cover the whole thing,
but nibble away, cover
a little bit, and then look
at the thing that you get,
which is that Q will become
some new thing, let's say Q1.
And now cover more
by Q1 minus Q1.
So apparently, if you do the
covering step more slowly,
you can obtain better bounds.
And that's enough to
save you this exponent,
to go down to polynomial-type
bounds for Freiman's theorem.
So I'm not giving details,
but this is roughly the idea.
So you can modify the final
step to obtain this bound.
The best bound so far is
due to Tom Sanders, who
proved Freiman's
theorem for bounds
on dimension that's
like K times poly log K,
and the size blowup to be E
to the K times poly log K.
So in other words, other than
this polylogarithmic factor,
it's basically the right answer.
And so this proof is
much more sophisticated.
So it goes much more
in depth into analyzing
the structure of set addition.
So Sanders has a very
nice survey article
called "The structure
of Set Addition"
that analyzes some of the
modern techniques that
are used to prove
these types of results.
There is one more
issue, which I want
to discuss at length in the
second half of this lecture,
which is that you
might be very unhappy
with this exponential blowup,
because if you think about what
happens in these examples--
I mean, not the examples, but
if you think about what happens,
like the spirit of what
we're trying to say,
Freiman's theorem is some
kind of an inverse theorem.
And to go forward,
you're trying to say
that if you have a GAP
of dimension d, then
the size blowup is
like 2 to the d.
So we want to say some structure
applies small doubling,
and Freiman's theorem
tells the reverse, that you
have small doubling, then
you obtain this structure.
And seems like you are losing.
Getting from here to here, there
is a polynomial type of loss,
whereas going from
here to here, it
seems that we're incurring
some exponential type of loss.
And it'll be nice to have
some kind of inverse theorem
that also preserves these
relationships qualitatively.
So that may not make
sense in this moment,
but we'll get back to
it later this lecture.
Point is, there's
more, much more
to be said about
the bounds here,
even though right now
it looks as if they're
very close to each other.
One more thing that
I want to expand on
is, we've stated and
proved Freiman's theorem
in the integers.
And you might ask, what
about in other groups?
We also proved Freiman's
theorem in F2 to the m, or more
generally, groups
of bounded exponent
or bounded portion, so abelian
groups of bounded exponent.
For general abelian groups,
so Freiman's theorem
in general abelian groups, you
might ask what happens here?
And in some sense what is even
the statement of the theorem?
So we want something
which combines,
somehow, two different
types of behavior.
On one hand, you have z,
which is what we just did.
And here the model
structures are GAP's.
And on the other hand, we
have, which we also proved,
things like F2 to the m,
where the model structures are
subgroups.
And there's a sense
in which these are not
the GAP's and subgroups.
They have some
similar properties,
but they're not really
like each other.
So now if I give you
a general group, which
might be some combination
of infinite torsion
or very large torsion elements
versus very small torsion
elements-- so for example,
take a Cartesian product
of these groups.
Is there a Freiman's theorem?
And what does such
a theorem look like?
What are the structures?
What are the subsets
of bounded doubling?
So that's kind of the thing
we want to think about.
So it turns out for Freiman's
theorem in general abelian
groups--
so there is a theorem.
So this theorem was
proved by Green and Ruzsa.
So following a very similar
type of proof framework,
although the individual
steps, in particular
the modeling lemma
needs to be modified.
And let me tell you
what the statement is.
So the common generalization
of GAP's and subgroups is
something called a
"co-set progression."
So a co-set
progression is a subset
which is a direct sum
of the form P plus H,
where P is a proper GAP.
So the definition of GAP works
just fine in every abelian
group.
You start with the initial
point, a few directions,
and you look at a grid
expansion of those directions.
P is a proper GAP,
and H is a subgroup.
And here, the direct sum
refers to the fact that every--
so if P plus H equals to P prime
plus H prime for some P and P
prime in the set P, and H
and H prime in the set H,
then P equals to P prime
and H equals to H prime.
So every element
in here is written
in a unique way as
some P plus some H. So
that's what I mean
by "direct sum."
For such an object, so
such a co-set progression,
I call its dimension to be
the dimension of the GAP, P.
And its size in
this case, actually,
is just the size of the set,
which is also the size of P
times the size of
H. So the theorem
is that if A is a subset of
an arbitrary abelian group
and it has bounded doubling,
then A is contained
in a co-set progression of
bounded dimension and size,
bounded blowup of the size of A.
And here, these constants
D and K are universal.
They do not depend on the group.
So there are some
specific numbers,
functions you can write down.
They do not depend on the group.
So this theorem gives
you the characterization
of subsets in general
abelian groups
that have small doubling.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: That's
a good question.
So I think you could
go into their paper
and see that you can get
polynomial type bounds.
And I think Sander's
results also
work for this type of setting to
give you these type of bounds.
But I-- yes, so you should
look into Sanders' paper,
and he will explain.
I think in Sanders' paper
he walks in general abelian
groups.
The next question I
want to address is--
well, what do you think
is the next question?
Non-abelian groups, so Freiman's
theorem in non-abelian groups,
or rather the Freiman problem
in non-abelian groups.
So here's a basic
question-- if I give you
a non-abelian group, what
subsets have bounded doubling?
Of course, the examples
from abelian groups
also work in non-abelian groups,
where you have subgroups,
you have generalized
arithmetical progressions.
But are there
genuinely new examples
of sets in non-abelian groups
that have bounded doubling?
So think about that, and
let's take a quick break.
Can you think of examples
in non-abelian groups
that have small doubling, that
do not come from the examples
that we have seen before?
So let me show you
one construction.
And this is that
important construction
for non-abelian groups.
So it has a name.
It's called a discrete
Heisenberg group,
which is the matrix group
consisting of matrices that
look like what I've written.
So you have integer
entries above the diagonal,
1 on the diagonal, and
0 below the diagonal.
So let's do some
elementary matrix
multiplication to see how group
multiplication in this group
works.
So if I have two such matrices,
I multiply them together.
And then you see
that the diagonal
is preserved, of course.
But this entry over
here is simply addition.
So this entry here
is just addition.
This entry over here
is also addition.
And the top right entry
is a bit more complicated.
It's some addition, but
there's an additional twist.
So this is how
matrix multiplication
works in this group.
I mean, this is how
matrix multiplication
works, but in terms of
elements of this group, that's
what happens.
So you see it's kind of
like an abelian group,
but there's an extra twist,
so it's almost abelian, so
the first step you can
take away from abelian.
And there's a way to
quantify this notion.
It's called "nilpotency."
And we'll get to
that in a second.
But in particular, if you
set S to be the following
generators--
so if you take S to be
these four elements,
and you ask what does the
r-th power of S look like,
so I look at all
the elements which
can be written by r or at
most r elements from S,
what do these
elements look like?
What do you think?
So if you look at
elements in here,
how large can this entry,
the 1, comma, 2 entry be?
r.
So each time you do
addition, so it's at most r.
So let me be a bit rough
here, and say it's big O of r.
And likewise, the 2, 1, 2,
3, entry is also big O of r.
What about the top
right entry over here?
So it grows like r
squared, because there is
an extra multiplication term.
So you can be much more
precise about the growth rate
of these individual entries.
But very roughly, it looks
like this ball over here.
So the size of S,
the r-th ball of S,
is roughly, it's on the
order of 4th power of r.
So in particular, the
doubling constant,
if r is reasonably
large, is what?
What happens when
we go from r to 2r?
The size increases by
a factor of around 16.
So that's an example of a
set in a non-abelian group
with bounded doubling,
which is genuinely
different from the examples
we have seen so far.
So that's non-abelian.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: The question
is, is the size--
we've shown the size is--
I'm not being very
precise here, but you can
do upper bound and lower bound.
So size turns out to be
the order of r to the 4.
So you want to show
that there are actually
enough elements over here
that you can fill in,
but I'll leave that to you.
Can you build other
examples like this one?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do
we know that this
isn't similar to a co-set,
the direct sum [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: Question
is, how do we
know this isn't like a co-set
sum or a co-set progression?
For one thing, this
is not abelian.
S, if you multiply entries
of S in different orders,
you get different elements.
So already in that way, it's
different from the examples
that we have seen before.
But no, you're right.
So maybe we can write
this a semi-direct product
in terms of things
we have seen before.
And it is, in some sense,
a semi-direct product,
but it's a very special
kind of semi-direct product.
From that example, you can
build bigger examples, of course
with more entries in the matrix.
But more generally,
these things are
what are known as
"nilpotent groups."
So that's an example
of a nilpotent group.
And to remind you, the
definition of a nilpotent group
is a group where the lower
central series eventually
terminates.
In particular, inside
that if you look at--
so this is the commutator of
G, so look at all the elements
that we recognize
x, y, x inverse,
y inverse-- the set of elements
that can be written this way.
So that's a subgroup.
And if I repeat this
operation enough times,
I eventually would
get just the identity.
And you could trade
on that group.
If you do the commutator,
so essentially you get rid
of abelian-ness and you
move up the whole diagonal,
you create a commutator,
you'd get rid of these--
all these two entries.
So you get z alone.
If you do it one more time,
you zero out that entry.
And so more generally, all
of these nilpotent groups
have this phenomenon, have the
polynomial growth phenomenon.
So if you take a set of
generators and look at a ball,
and look at the
volume of the ball,
how does the volume of the
ball grow with the radius?
It grows like a polynomial.
And so let me define that.
So given G, a finitely generated
group, so generated by set S,
we say that G has polynomial
growth if the size S to the r
grows like at most
a polynomial in r.
It's worth noting that
this definition is really
a definition about
G. It does not depend
on the choice of generators.
You can have different choices,
generators for the group.
But if it has polynomial
growth with respect
to one set of generators,
then it's the same.
It also has polynomial
growth with regards
to every other set.
So we've seen an example of
groups with polynomial growth.
Abelian groups have
polynomial growth.
So if you think of
polynomial growth,
think lattice or z to the m.
So if you take a
ball growing, so it
has size growing like
r to the dimension.
But nilpotent groups
is another example
of groups with
polynomial growth.
And these are, intuitively
at least for now, related
to bounded doubling.
If it's polynomial growth,
then it has bounded doubling.
So is there a classification
of groups with bounded--
with polynomial growth?
So if I tell you a group--
so an infinite group always,
because otherwise if finite,
then it maxes out already
at some point.
So I give you an infinite group.
I tell you it has
polynomial growth.
What can you tell
me about this group?
Is there some
characterization that's
an inverse of what
we've seen so far?
And the answer is yes.
And this is a famous and
deep result of Gromov.
So Gromov's theorem on
groups of polynomial growth
from the '80s.
Gromov showed that
a finitely generated
group has polynomial
growth if and only
if it's virtually
nilpotent, where "virtually"
is an adverb in
group theory where
you have some property like
"abelian," or "solvable,"
or whatever.
So virtually P means that there
exists a finite index subgroup
with property P. So
"virtually nilpotent"
means there is a finite index
subgroup that is nilpotent.
So it completely characterizes
groups of polynomial growth.
So basically, all the
examples we've seen so far
are representative, so up to
changing by a finite index
subgroup, which as
you would expect,
shouldn't change the
growth nature by so much.
There are some analogies
to be made here with,
for example in geometry,
you ask in Euclidean space,
how fast is the ball
of radius r growing?
In dimension d, it
grows like r to the d.
What about in the
hyperbolic space?
Does anyone know how fast,
in a hyperbolic space,
a ball of radius r grows?
It's exponential in the radius.
So for non-negatively
curved spaces,
the balls grow polynomially.
But for something that's
negatively curvatured,
in particular the
hyperbolic space,
the ball growth
might be exponential.
You have a similar
phenomenon happening here.
The opposite of
polynomial growth
is, well, super
polynomial growth,
but one specific example is
that of a free group, where
there are no relations
between the generators.
In that case, the balls,
they grow like exponentially.
So the balls grow
exponentially in the radius.
Gromov's theorem
is a deep theorem.
And its original proof
used some very hard tools
coming from geometry.
And Gromov developed a notion
of convergence of metric spaces,
somewhat akin to our
discussion of graph limits.
So starting with
discrete objects,
he looked at some convergence
to some continuous objects,
and then used some
very deep results
from the classification
of locally compact groups
to derive this result over here.
So this proof has been
quite influential,
and is related to
something called
"Hilbert's fifth problem, which
concerns characterizations
of Lie groups.
So all of these are
inverse-type problems.
I tell you some structure
has some property.
Describe that structure.
What does this all have to
do with Freiman's theorem?
Already you see some relation.
So there seems, at least
intuitively, some relationship
between groups of polynomial
growth versus subsets
of bounded doubling.
One implies the other,
although not in the converse.
And they are indeed related.
And this comes out of
some very recent work.
I should also mention
that Gromov's theorem has
been made simplified
by Kleiner, who
gave an important
simplification, a more
elementary proof of
Gromov's theorem.
So let's talk about
the non-abelian version
of Freiman's theorem.
We would like some
result that says
that is it true that every
set, most every set of--
so previously, we
had small doubling.
You want to have some similar
notion, although it may not
be exactly small doubling,
but let me not be very precise
and to say, "small doubling."
In literature, these things
are sometimes also known
as "approximate groups."
So if you look this up, you will
get to the relevant literature
on the subject.
Most every set of small doubling
in some non-abelian group
behaves like one of these
known examples, something
which is some combination of
subgroups and nilpotent balls.
So these combinations are
sometimes known as "co-set
nilprogressions."
So this was something
that was only
explored in the
past 10 years or so
in a series of very
difficult works.
Previously, it had
been known, and still
was being investigated for
various special classes
of matrix groups or
special classes of groups
like solvable
groups and whatnot,
that are more explicit
or easier to handle
or closer to the abelian analog.
There was important
work of Hrushovski,
which was published
about 10 years ago,
who showed using model
theory techniques,
so using methods from
logic, that a weak version
of Freiman's theorem is
true for non-abelian groups.
And later on, Breuillard, Green,
and Tao building on Hrushovskis
work-- so this actually
came quite a bit later,
even though the journal
publication dates are the same
year--
so they were able to build
on Hrushovski's work,
and greatly expanding on it, and
going back to some of the older
techniques coming from Hilbert's
fifth problem, and as a result,
proved an inverse
structure theorem
that gave some kind of
answer to this question
of non-abelian Freiman.
So we now do have
some theorem which
is like Freiman's theorem
for abelian groups that
says in a non-abelian group,
if you have something that
resembles small doubling, then
the set must, in some sense,
look like a combination of
subgroups and nilpotent balls.
But let me not be
precise at all.
The methods here
build on Hrushovski.
And Hrushovski used model
theory, which is kind of--
it's something
where-- in particular,
one feature of all
of these proofs
is that they give no bounds.
Similar to what we've seen
earlier in the course,
in proofs that involved
compactness, what happens
here is that the arguments
use ultra filters.
So there are these constructions
from mathematical logic.
And like compactness,
they give no bounds.
So it remains an open problem
to prove Freiman's theorem
for non-abelian groups
with some concrete bounds.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
nilpotent ball?
YUFEI ZHAO: What
is nilpotent ball?
I don't want to give
a precise definition,
but roughly speaking,
it's balls that
come out of those
types of constructions.
So you take a
nilpotent subgroup.
You take a nilpotent group.
You look at an image
of a nilpotent group
into your group, and then look
at the image of that ball, so
something that looks like one
of the previous constructions.
So that's all I want to say
about non-abelian extensions
of Freiman's theorem.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Would you
say one more time
what you mean by
"approximate group?"
YUFEI ZHAO: So what I mean by--
you can look in the papers and
see the precise definitions,
but roughly speaking,
it's that if you have--
there are different kinds of
definitions and most of them
are equivalent.
But one version is
that you have a set A
such that A is coverable
by K translates of A,
so it's a bit more than
just the size information,
but it's actually related
to size information.
So we've already seen in
this course how many of these
different notions can go
back and forth from one
to the other, covering
to size, and whatnot.
The final thing I
want to discuss today
is one of the most
central open problems
in additive combinatorics going
back to the abelian version.
So this is known as the
"polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture."
So we would like some
kind of a Freiman theorem
that preserves the constants
up to polynomial changes
without losing an exponent.
Now, from earlier
discussions, I showed you
that the bounds that we almost
proved is close to the truth.
You do need some kind
of exponential loss
in the blowup size of the GAP.
But it turns out
those kind of examples
are slightly misleading.
So let's look at the examples
of the constructions again.
So if A-- so just for
simplicity in exposition,
I'm going to stick with F2
to the n, at least initially.
So if A is an independent
set of size n,
then K, being the
doubling constant of A,
is roughly like n over 2.
And yet the subgroup
that contains A
has size 2 to the something
on the order of K times A.
So you necessarily incur an
exponential loss over here.
Now, you might complain that the
size of A here is basically K.
But of course, I can
blow up this example
by considering what happens
if you take each element here,
and blow it up into
an entire subspace.
So the e's are the
coordinate vectors.
So now I'm sitting inside
F2 to the m plus n.
And that gives me this set.
The doubling constant is
still the same as before.
And yet, we see that the
subgroup generated by A
still has this
exponential blowup
in this constant, exponential
in the doubling constant.
But now you see in
this example here,
even though the
subgroup generated by A
can be much larger than A, so
everything's still constant, so
much larger in terms of as
a function of the doubling
constant, A has a
very large structure.
So A contains a
very large subspace.
By "subspace," I
mean affine subspace.
And the subspace here is
comparable to the size
of A itself.
So you might
wonder, if you don't
care about containing A
inside a single subspace,
can you do much better
in terms of bounds?
And that's the content of
the polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture.
The PFR conjecture
for F2 to the m
says that if you have
a subset of F2 to the m
and A plus A is size at
most K times the size of A,
then there exists a
subspace V of size
at most A such that V contains
a large proportion of A.
And the large here--
we only lose something that is
polynomial in these doubling
constants.
So that's the case.
It's over here.
So instead of containing A
inside an entire subspace,
I just want to contain a large
fraction of A in a subspace.
And the conjecture
is that I do not
need to incur exponential
losses in the constants.
AUDIENCE: So V is
an affine subspace?
YUFEI ZHAO: V is--
question is, V is
an affine subspace.
You can think of V as
You can think of
V as a subspace.
It doesn't actually matter
in this formulation.
There's an equivalent
formulation
which you might like better,
where you might complain,
initially, PFR is initially--
Freiman's theorem
is about covering
A. And now we've only
covered a part of A.
But of course, we saw
from earlier arguments,
you can use Ruzsa's
covering lemma to go
from covering a part of
A to covering all of A.
Indeed, it this the case
that this formulation
is equivalent to the
formulation that if A
is in F to the n and A plus
A size at most K times A,
then there exists some subspace
V with the size of V no larger
than the size of
A, such that A can
be covered by polynomial
in K many co-sets of V.
We see that here.
Here A has doubling constant K,
which is around the same as n.
And even though I cannot
contain A by a single subspace
of roughly the same size, I
can use K different translates
to cover A. Any questions?
So I want to leave it
to you as an exercise
to prove that these two versions
are equivalent to each other.
It's not too hard.
It's something if I had
more time, I would show you.
It uses Ruzsa covering lemma
to prove this equivalence.
The nice thing about the--
so the polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture, PFR conjecture,
is considered a
central conjecture
in additive combinatorics,
because it has many equivalent
formulations and relates
to many problems that
are central to the subject.
So we would like some kind of an
inverse theorem that gives you
these polynomial bounds.
And I'll mention a couple of
these equivalent formulations.
Here is an equivalent
formulation
which is rather attractive,
where instead of considering
subsets, we're
going to formulate
something that has to do with
approximate homomorphisms.
So the statement
still conjecture
is that if F is a function
from a Boolean space
to another Boolean space is
such that F is approximately
a homomorphism in the sense that
the set of possible errors--
so if it's actually
a homomorphism,
then this quantity is
always equal to 0--
but it's approximately a
homomorphism in the sense
that the set of such errors
is bounded by K in size,
the conclusion, the conjecture
claims that then there
exists an actual homomorphism,
an actual linear map G,
such that F is
very close to G, as
in that the set of possible
discrepancies between F and G
is bounded, where you only
lose at most a polynomial in K.
So if you are an approximate
homomorphism in this sense,
then you are actually very
close to an actual linear map.
Now, it is not too hard to prove
a much quantitatively weaker
version of this statement.
So I claim that it is trivial
to show upper bound of at most 2
to the K over here.
So think about that.
So if I give you
an F, I can just
think about what the values
of F are on the basis,
and extend it to a linear map.
Then this set is necessarily
a span of that set,
so has size at most 2 to the K.
But it's open to show you only
have to lose a polynomial in K.
There is also a version of
the polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture which is related to
things we've discussed earlier
regarding Szemeredi's theorem.
And in fact, the polynomial
Freiman-Ruzsa conjecture kind
of came back into
popularity partly because
of Gowers' proof of
Szemeredi's theorem
that used many of these tools.
So let me state it here.
So we've seen some statement
like this in an earlier
lecture, but not very precisely
or not precisely in this form.
And I won't define for
you all the notation here,
but hopefully, you get a rough
sense of what it's about.
So we want some kind
of an inverse statement
for what's known as a
"quadratic uniformity norm,"
"quadratic Gowers'
uniformity norm."
So recall back to our discussion
of the proof of Roth's theorem,
the Fourier analytic
proof of Roth's theorem.
We want to say that--
but now think about not
three APs, but four APs.
So we want to know if you have a
function F on the Boolean cube,
and this function
is 1 bounded, and--
I'm going to write down
some notation, which
we are not going to define--
but the Gowers' u3 norm
is at least some delta.
So this is something which
is related to 4 AP counts.
So in particular, if
this number is small,
then you have a counting
lemma for four-term arithmetic
progressions.
If this is true, then there
exists a quadratic polynomial q
in n variables over F2
such that your function
F correlates with this
quadratic exponential in q.
And the correlation here is
something where you only lose
a polynomial in the parameters.
So previously, I
quoted something
where you lose something that's
only a constant in delta,
and that is true.
That is known.
But we believe, so
it's conjecture,
that you only lose a
polynomial in these parameters.
So this type of
statement-- remember,
in our proof of Roth's theorem,
something like this came up.
So something like this
came up as a crucial step
in the proof of Roth's theorem.
If you have something where
you look at counting lemma,
and you exhibit
something like this,
then you can exhibit a
large Fourier character.
And in higher order
Fourier analysis,
something like this
corresponds to having
a large Fourier transform.
It turns out that all
of these formulations
of polynomial
Freiman-Ruzsa conjecture
are equivalent to each other.
And they're all equivalent
in a very quantitative sense,
so up to polynomial
changes in the bounds.
So in particular,
if you can prove
some bound for some version,
then that automatically
leads to bounds for
the other versions.
The proof of equivalences
is not trivial,
but it's also not
too complicated.
It takes some work, but
it's not too complicated.
The best bounds for the
polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture, and hence for
all of these versions,
is again due to Tom Sanders.
And he proved a version of PFR
with quasi-polynomial bounds,
where by "quasi-polynomial
bounds," I mean,
for instance over
here, instead of K.
He proved it for something which
is like e to the poly log K,
so like K to the log K,
but K to the poly log K.
So it's almost polynomial,
but not quite there.
And it's considered a
central open problem
to better understand the
polynomial Freiman-Ruzsa
conjecture.
And we believe that
this is something
that could lead to a lot
of important new tools
and techniques that are
relevant to the rest
of additive combinatorics.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Using the fact that
all of these are equivalent,
is it possible to get a proof
of Freiman's theorem using
the bound of 2 to the K to
be approximate [INAUDIBLE]??
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so
the question is,
we know that that up
there has 2 to the K,
so you're asking can
you use this 2 to the K
to get some bound
for polynomial,
for something like this?
And the answer is yes.
So you can use that proof
to go through some proofs
and get here.
I don't remember how this
equivalence goes, but remember
that the proof of Freiman's
theorem for F2 to the n
wasn't so hard.
So we didn't use
very many tools.
Unfortunately, I don't
have time to tell you
the formulations of polynomial
Freiman-Ruzsa conjecture
over the integers, and also
over arbitrary abelian groups.
But there are formulations
over the integers,
and that's one that people
care just as much about.
And there are also different
equivalent versions,
but things are a bit
nicer in the Boolean case.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said [INAUDIBLE]?
YUFEI ZHAO: I'm sorry, can
you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, what does that mean?
YUFEI ZHAO: Are you asking
what does this mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YUFEI ZHAO: So this is what's
called a "Gowers' uniformity
norm."
So something I encourage
you to look up.
In fact, there is an unassigned
problem in the problem set
that's related to the
Gowers' uniformity norm
before you U2, which just
relates to Fourier analysis.
But U3 is related to 4 AP's
and quadratic Fourier analysis.